vous avez entendu début du reportage
vous avez un groupe qui dort c'est vrai
écoutez moi j'ai vu surtout une
président de la commission qui est là en
l'occurrence rapporteur qui était
extrêmement active sur ses plaies groupe
harles et naïm amoutchou notamment qui
est la responsable du groupe nous en
commission qui a été présente à tous les
instants on s'est beaucoup réunit aussi
en groupe c'est à dire et à la fois les
gens de la commission des lois qui sont
réunis puis ça a été élargie aussi à
toutes celles et ceux qui avaient envie
de contribuer sur ce texte par exemple
je suis passé en commission des lois
mais on a contribué on a proposé des
amendements dont certains qui ont été
pré en commission des lois dont je pense
que voilà on doit avoir une collégialité
sur ce texte qui est essentiel vous
répondez pas vraiment la question mais
moi je moi écouter j'ai vu un groupe qui
était actif qui était présent à la fois
en commission des lois en réunion de
groupe est soudé c'est ça qui compte
parce que le fils au final c'est le
texte qui sort de la commission des lois
qui est important ce texte il me semble
cohérent on anticipait des soi-disant
recul vous voyez qu'il n'y sont pas bien
au contraire et ça a pu créer de la
polémique plutôt avec l'opposition qui
aurait aimé qu'on aille moins loin et
c'est ça que je retiens c'est ce que le
texte va dire et c'est ça qui est
essentiel avant